you know I walked in this morning and
Robyn's in a glass booth so she can't
hear me so it's almost like a game of
charades so I'm trying to act out I
called you last night and you don't even
know it but you know what your sign
language is terrible you would not be
the person who invented sign for the
deaf
well I assumed you already knew that I
called you and you knew what I was
referring to but of course you didn't
well you don't put your egg so that you
I made a phone to me right but you
didn't you don't have any time signature
whether you're going to call me I've
already called me you'd be terribly I
should do charades with you let me give
you good Fred write down a name of a
title it's somebody a movie just write
down the name of a title of a movie okay
and I will act it out for Robin let's
see how long it takes her due time how
long it takes her to get because it was
all right all right here we go
I hate games but all right here we are
you set in the clock I am alright here
we go
when I start you start Fred you got
alright four words
blown you blown are you drowning are you
what you you can't breathe terrible at
this underwater Harold or someone else
oh there was at least 30 seconds it was
you don't see I'm making wind
department-id I said no you did what is
wind wind you got one word so far okay
alright go ahead come what's the gutter
with the way I'm with the weak very good
boy are you bad
but I said blown you didn't you go no
that was terrible and I was like yeah I
know how to do that and I don't even
know how to do how do you do gone gone
with the wind I just were trying what
gone I'm not gonna act out dawn is gonna
walk out and never come back
he's going Oh gone with the wind you
were horrible I was what blows you away
but then you win say all right give me
way in that department here's one more
you're terrible and then you look like
you were swimming uh you know like
what's this pumping out your cheeks when
you're blown all right you ready all
right all right
movie two words you're looking for
something see look when I hold up to I
mean second word I can't see
he's he's fighting a battle I just acted
out the whole thing
you're fighting a battle two words the
first word or the second word would you
put your glasses on I held up two
fingers and you got first word are you
kidding me oh here we go get it say it
word war the first word you only gave me
it's two words war which war Star Wars
there you go
[ __ ] home that's got a minute and 15
seconds holy cow no wonder you don't
understand my message you're the worst
oh how good was I Fred wasn't I doing
him I thought you were trying to do very
well but it's like you don't realize how
difficult it is right he knows what that
was second word I acted out yeah I got
that that took you half 45 but I'm
trying to relate I didn't oh never mind
holy mackerel one more come on anything
I'm missing a role morning play charades
with you we're being paid for this all
right one more Fred give me an easy one
did she says she's over there she she
wants to look good I again right I'm
terrific at this I didn't realize I'll
be so good a terminator how would I act
that out I don't I can't even imagine I
can't do Star Wars forget about
determinants I'm drawing a blank right
now oh wait no prize it's only ten
million movies I know I'm just drawing a
blank on this by the way next Robin and
I will play tic-tac-toe on the radio I'm
gonna make it alright you ready
okay so raids I hate charades but
alright though I'm making a point I
think I was signaling you that I can see
your signs were bad and it still holds
just won this one I think is possible
all right
is it okay okay here we go
all right three words word number to
your old backaches you're in pain
backache
I hate this game okay first word first
Brokeback Mountain thank you God just
keep going thank you don't yell at me
you did it under 45 seconds
yeah better badder ninety get it I have
a heart attack from this game so much
pressure my acting is awesome sure you
want to try and although now oh come on
that's ridiculous
three people are now listening